how are you Adam hello there it's how
you doing is it I'm great thank you
better for you calling in is it me or
they're more holdouts than then in
recent years that we go if we go back to
the mandatory mini camps there was an
outbreak hold outs of veterans that I
don't think we've seen in any any other
year it was far more than normal and now
this year lovely eyes and centers for
antenna so he cannot be considerable but
even though he's not there at Camp Julio
Jones is you know coherent ah for sure
well Thomas oh sure that's three right
there till illa Wan decided to report
Khalil Mack is in question still that
could be another and I think it's just a
continuation a carryover from what we
saw a mandatory minicamp square these
players look Aaron Donald I believe he's
in the fifth year option right now
Khalil Mack is in the future option old
Thomas is in the last year deal with
Joan different category three years left
on the deal different circumstances
surrounding everybody but again unrest
amongst the players and I don't know if
it's on the heels of the players seeing
the NBA contracts if that has anything
to do with it I don't think so I just
think these guys are just they want more
guarantees they want a bigger piece of
the pie they see other people getting
more salaries the salaries accelerate
every year at a greater and greater pace
because there's more money in the cap
and so a player like Leo Jones wants his
cut of the pie and he's not getting it
right now well Adam I mean you know I
think you're hitting on something I
think the NBA salaries definitely are
are being put in front of a lot of these
players on Twitter or Instagram they
probably follow a lot of the NBA players
and they're friends with them or they do
pickup games with some of them and I
think they see that and and I think part
of it too is you know just seeing how
how fantasy play is becoming more
prevalent in the world and when I say
that I mean so many Millennials might
not be rooting for an actual team like
you know I grew up with
you know we grew up with our favorite
team poster on the wall or dare I say
the sheets and pillowcases with all the
logos of the NFL teams on them right
but the Millennials teams are their
fantasy teams and I think right I think
players are kind of viewing their value
that in that too and I just don't know
how that manifests itself in an actual
paycheck and it's also it's also more
about they say this like rich you know
I'm older I'm 51 now but the younger
generation more of a me generation right
so it's all about taking care of
themselves as they should they should
take care of themselves I don't say that
it's criticism football players get
every penny they can when they get it
but there I believe I don't I can look I
think they're there they're definitely
one more training camp minicamp holdouts
than ever before and I think it's only
stands to reason that there'd be more
training camp holdouts than ever before
and there are some flaws with the system
that needs to be addressed that 50 year
option there's contracts is is
horrendous it cost players a lot of
money and I think that some of these
things have to be addressed in the next
round of CBA talks and I think will be
addressed at some point and those see be
it but it's right now though the players
have to deal with that and there there's
a lot of money to go around but they
want to make sure they get their pot and
or their portion and if they don't
they're not reporting as we say so that
which one do you think has the the legs
to maybe hit the regular-season I mean
with Julio Jones you've got a guy who
who has is making less dollars on the
back end of a contract that has more
than a year left and in Aaron Donald he
wants to from what everything I'm
hearing he wants to be paid like a
quarterback the same thing with levy on
bail maybe in a way what what I guess
everybody's got different reasons for
holding out or Thomas - which one do you
think has the most legs here but my
understanding is that Earl Thomas is in
absolutely zero rush to get to Seattle
and won't be there anytime soon if ever
so we'll see how that plays out again
you can talk tough and say a lot of
things on July 25th a different thing
when it's August 25th in the regular
season is creeping close and the checks
get real and the games get real and
we'll see what happens then
but I think world Thomas threatens to
last into the season and I think Aaron
Donald frankly I'll be surprised if you
please another down on his current
contract so you tell me when they're
gonna get that contract child and I'll
tell you what I'm gonna see him well
what does he ask you for best you can
tell Adam I would say rich that that's a
deal if you just look at it there's no
reason that Aaron Donald shouldn't be
asking to become the highest-paid
richest defensive in the game and I'm
sure that's something that he's probably
looking for so if that's the case we
just go find the highest-paid the
pitcher
put Aaron Donald slot him in above that
and you begin to get a general idea of
the vicinity of the deal that you'd be
looking for mm-hmm and how significant
is the Gurley contract in terms of
breaking of precedents or setting a new
bar that levee on bail obviously was
tweeting out Adam Schefter
is a big deal and he's a big deal with a
lot of ramifications the running backs
needed somebody to crack that ceiling
nobody had done that it was a depressed
salary market you could say sake on
Berkeley except his was a slotted salary
for being the second overall pick you
could say levy on bail is a French I
take but under the franchise tick there
hadn't been a running back in recent
year who had gotten the kind of deal
that Gurley got was basically is fifteen
million dollars a year on the extension
45 in guarantees and so I could tell you
this david johnson and i rizona very
happy Ezekiel Elliott in Dallas very
happy and even levy on bail yesterday
tweeted the fact you thought I was all
tripping I guess not because he thought
he turned on a deal that was averaging
15 million dollars a year in the first
three years clearly thinking he was
worth more and so yesterday brought him
some validation I think now that doesn't
mean he was right and turning it down I
still think that again if it were me and
I were his agent and advising him which
I wasn't I would say when you're running
back and you've got the tread that you
have and you've had some of the off to
field issues that you've had and they're
waving 30-plus million dollars in
guaranteed money in front of you the 15
million dollar yourself you take that
you don't try to play that out to get to
16 or 17 a year if
not worth the ups but a lot of times
that these players rich it becomes a
point of pride and a principal and levy
on bail felt like he single-handedly
wanted to reset the running back market
he did not want to hold it back and do
it damage and he did he felt was right
I don't it's not what I would have done
but it's what he chose and he very well
may be rewarded for it this offseason if
he gets that seventeen million dollar a
year deal but you got a fine team that
has a running back need with the calf
space that's willing to spend and if all
those factors come together
Le'Veon Bell will play this just right
and if they don't then it becomes a
question Adam Schefter from the
worldwide leader in sports a few more
minutes serving as the NFL insider the
rookie quarterback most likely to start
what we threw it right in for me here
how did Josh Rosen or Baker may feel
probably like I don't think San Thor
would be ready right away and they're
not gonna rush him McGowan and Teddy
Bridgewater they're Josh Allen again I
think needs time and AJ McCarron and
Nathan Peterman I think will be ready
for the opener vying for that starting
job Josh Rosen I think there's a
realistic chance to win that starting
job you can't he plays great and Baker
maple I know the Browns want to start
Tyrod Taylor and Ken to start Tyra is
that and why is that
because they believe in him they traded
a pick for him they think he's the right
guy they don't want to rush me fuel but
here's the thing and I say this for any
of these rookie quarterbacks rich if any
one of these rookie quarterbacks comes
out and shows that like Russell Wilson
did his rookie in a preseason when he
was a rookie these teams can have a hard
time keeping them on the bench just
going to and so Baker Mayfield comes in
and plays an appreciation the way that
the Browns Hopi will and the way they
fake he can think you have to think that
he's have a chance to unseat Tyrod
Taylor early and then there's the case
of a guy who can't stay on the bench
because he's too damn dynamic to keep
their and in the case of Lamar Jackson
how is that playing out best you can
tell in Baltimore you know he's a ways
away you know I
the best thing that he is gonna do for
that team this year uh he'll obviously
bring some bring some bring some big
playability
but I think he's already had a huge
effect on this team and that is the
sense that I it's really jump-started
Joe Flacco and really brought him some
added motivation that would not have
been there in other years and we see
that in the form of him working out and
what wide receivers in the offseason
when she's never done before we see it
if you keep talk to the people around
there they say he seems a little bit
different a little edgier and and I
think that anyone any competitor when
he's challenged like that is gonna
respond in a favorable fashion I think
the Ravens believe that Joe Flacco is
doing that right now and that maybe
Lamar Jackson's greatest contribution
this season couple more quick hitters
with you Adam Schefter Carson Wentz
starting on pop appears for training
camp what about the regular season you
think he starts with listen he's still
very far ahead where they thought he
would be and so they're just gonna be
very careful it's July 25th again it's
not August 25th Murray and Carson Wentz
is ahead of where they thought he would
be
they are very encouraged about that I
think there's a realistic chance he's
gonna start the regular season opener
and I would never have thought that when
he suffered the injury that they said
would be at ninth month in December
which would have been a rush to get him
ready for the opener but he's course and
when's he Superman like and and I think
he is got a real chance to start that
opening night game against the Falcons
at home and lastly Adam what are you
hearing about the national anthem policy
I don't think that the NFL can and the
Players Association can afford to wait
till week one let's not forget Colin
Kaepernick first did sit for the anthem
during a preseason game
August 9th is right around the corner
the Hall of Fame game is one thing but
August 9th is right around the corner
you got a hundred guys maybe even
suiting up it's entirely possible it's
somebody you've never heard of nobody in
the league has ever heard of does
something that the league and the
players then have to own without with
this player having absolutely no shot at
actually representing an NFL team coming
up in September so what's the deadline
from what you're hearing about on this
thing you want me to answer a question
that a man who makes north of three
million dollars a year can answer
so you're saying you don't make that
much money is that what you're saying on
that's I'm saying I don't make that much
money rich and I'm saying that this is a
question that has confounded man's will
make a lot more than your I and they
can't come up with a solution to it and
they spent two years and they have got
it wrong basically a return of the way
and I thought in my mind the issue was
dying down in the spring when they
decided to enact a new policy to me at
that point I think the best thing to do
would have just been leave it alone let
everybody do what they want to do and
hope it just kind of fades into the
background because it seemed to be doing
that I mean didn't you tell me didn't to
talk of it died down absolutely there's
no question but the nba's got a stronger
policy a demand nothing happens in the
NBA and it's not as if the NBA does not
have socially conscious people who are
trying to address the same issues at NFL
players or addressing and that's why a
lot of people think it's because of the
relationship between players and owners
why this sort of thing hasn't been
solved and when I saw that this this
policy was being reviewed by the two
sides together that gave me a little bit
of an appreciation for the mulligan to
be honest with you that's why I'm asking
about what do you think is being
discussed well I I think what's being
discussed right now is when they're
going to discuss it because they're
gonna be meeting again you know in the
next week or two right to see if they
can come up with a solution
so I don't I don't know that the two
sides which which I believe is
imperative here I think the NFL needs to
cooperation the players and the players
it would be great if they had their
input in the situation but I don't
believe they're discussing actively the
two sides of solution I think that right
now discussing dates to try to figure
out when they could sit down to discuss
a solution that works for everybody do I
see you in Kenton you're gonna be no how
next week not invited this year itch
what I'll invite you come on out I
appreciate you if you send me a plane
ticket I'll come on out hey listen Adam
you have been many you have many times
provided a space for somebody in the
hotel room a Kotik a rollaway bed just
return the favor okay I hear a lot of
chuckles of the best
do the best I'm sorry you bet same see
me of Chester after the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience